um as far as the corner spot you know
kyle uh
obviously he's heavily involved and he's
got um
uh we're evaluating it every day and and
when coach
shanahan is ready to pull the trigger
he'll pull the trigger so um but
as of now it's it's still a work in
progress
49ers have one of the great cornerbacks
of recent
years on one side of the field on the
other side they don't know
who they're going to have and you know
it's richard sherman really has
tightened his grip
on that defense and you know there was
talk a year ago that if jason verret had
worked out well for the 49ers in
training camp in the preseason the 49ers
may have moved on from richard sherman i
don't know if he caught wind of that and
that motivated him to play at a higher
level
but but it he's really had this career
rebirth but
if you only have one starting corner
that you feel good about
and the other one you don't and you
don't know who it's going to be
you know they're just going to throw to
that side of the field you got to have
two guys who can play
or they're going to they're going to
exploit the one guy that's viewed as a
weakness and i don't know where they're
going to go
but it's something that they need to be
concerned about if they want to slow
down opposing offenses this year shireen
poor jason verrette i mean i watched him
at tcu and he came into the league and
he got hurt and then his second year he
made the pro bowl and and he looked
great just like they thought it was
going to be and then he got hurt again
and and that's been the story for him
you know with the chargers he he
just couldn't get back on the field and
couldn't return to being the guy he was
and now suddenly he has a hamstring
injury again by all accounts he looked
really good
in training camp and now he's hurt again
who knows how long he'll be out but the
guy just
just can't stay on the field he's
playing less than 30 games in his career
and we've kind of forgotten about
who he is but emmanuel mosley won that
job last year and started at the end of
the year and
you know you think that's going to be
the guy they have a lot of choices there
but i i think they would love veret to
win that job but he just can't seem to
stay healthy so it's probably going to
end up being
emmanuel mosley starting opposite
richard sherman but i think it's still a
big question mark
for the 49ers if i'm looking at their
team that's probably one of the question
marks i have for them and there are very
few for that team
and even though sherman still has great
instincts and there have been stories
about how he's been picking off jimmy
garoppolo in practice in part because he
knows the offense so well because they
face it all the time he'll peel away
from
his receiver and grab the ball as it's
heading toward
the receiver someone else is covering we
saw it in the postseason
the nfc championship game how devante
adams got by him and sammy watkins who
said after
super bowl 54 he studied that tape he
saw what adams did
and that was what watkins did to get
past richard sherman on what ended up
being a key play on the go-ahead drive
i mean if if you've got a corner that
that
from time to time is gonna get flat out
burned on a deep ball that's a problem
too if that's your number one guy so uh
all the more reason for that that front
four
it doesn't matter who's playing corner
and safety if your front four
is getting to the quarterback so quickly
that the quarterback has no
chance to even see that there's a guy
running down the field wide open and i
think that's where the strength
of the 49ers defense is and and maybe
that's the thing that ultimately
will will keep richard sherman or
emmanuel mosey or akilo weatherspoon
cowan williams dante johnson jason
verrett whoever's playing corner from
being exposed
they they have very limited time to be
exposed because
the front four is going to be all over
the quarterback
boy doesn't a great pass rush make your
cornerbacks look so much better i mean
we've seen it
year after year after year with with
teams and and it does make a huge
difference and you don't have to have
those great corners if the quarterback
doesn't have much time and
and that's what happens when you play
the 49ers defense you don't have much
time against that pass rush and if those
pass rushers stay healthy
quarterbacks not going to have much time
which makes that cornerback
opposite richard sherman and richard
sherman look better probably than what
they are
yeah i agree with you completely and
nick bosa who's weak to weak with a
lower body injury they need him back
when i heard week to week last week i
thought man he may not be available for
week one or maybe beyond week to week is
not a good sign
and without him that's a different pass
rush all together so
uh even though the 49ers one of the best
teams in the nfl last year they're back
at zero and zero like everyone else and
they got to start digging
and if if they've got some weaknesses
and we've seen some injuries as well
particularly at receiver they just put
table on austin on ir yesterday and
they've had other
receivers who are injured in debo samuel
there are questions about him
this team just may not be ready to hit
the ground running the way that it did
last year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports